Screen Actors Guild please prepare
yourself sit down
pull over if you're driving this is
gonna this is going to be tough
The Screen Actors Guild is going on
strike
okay moving on the SAG someone sag is
the Screen Actors Guild emerged about 10
years ago with after the American
Federation of Television radio artists
uh voted unanimously to go on strike and
they will be joining another strike in
Hollywood which is the writer's Guild of
America strike and that means
effectively that unionized Hollywood is
shut down and sag is kind of a crappy
Union back in my wayward youth I would
occasionally work with the Screen Actors
Guild as a professional actor and it's
not a great Union because they're at any
given time like 99 of its membership is
unemployed because actors have hard
times getting jobs generally and so all
of these radical leftists who were
largely unemployed just voted to go on
strike but the the
sag union doesn't do a lot for actors
generally The Writer's Guild actually is
a pretty good union for its members sag
doesn't do all that much and so in
recent years a lot of professional
actors a lot of huge name actors have
have gone Phi core which a financial
core which is to say they don't they
don't really go along with the Union
they'll pay their dues because they have
to as a result of a court case but they
don't really care the influence of the
Screen Actors Guild has waned
dramatically just as the influence of
unions especially in Hollywood has Wayne
Hollywood has waned dramatically and
that's really the point here
the writers are going on strike the
actors are going on strike does anybody
care
when was the last time you went out to
see a movie I bet just judging by box
office numbers the last time you went
out to see a movie was to go see the
sound of Freedom starring Jim Caviezel
which is a movie that was made largely
outside of Hollywood
Jim caviezel's a terrific actor he's a
big Hollywood star
the movie was funded basically by just a
bunch of kooky conservatives and then it
was made by a bunch of Highly skilled
professionals who were
disenchanted with the way that the
Hollywood studio system works
other than that what shows are you
watching I'm not watching any shows
right now you know what show I'm
watching right now occasionally I'll put
on an episode of Father Brown from the
BBC
I don't I don't even know what's coming
out of Hollywood the only movies that I
would be even tempted to see in
Hollywood
it's Mission Impossible I guess just
Mission Impossible
I don't even know I'd like to go see the
last movie star on Earth Tom Cruise
maybe I would go see him in a movie
other than that I don't even know what
they're producing I'm a culture vulture
I worked in Hollywood for a considerable
amount of time I've worked in New York I
like the Arts I read poetry I read plays
I should be the
number one audience the number one fan
for these things and yet I'm tuning out
and you're tuning out and this is
reflected in the
completely collapsing viewership of the
Academy Awards the collapsing viewership
not just in movies and theaters but even
of the big Hollywood films on streaming
it's over guys so okay you're gonna
you're going to protest okay you don't
have any leverage anymore
fine the writers and the actors are
going on strike fine by me man that's
what we're gonna go watch sound of sound
of Freedom right now go to geniusell.com
Knowles our friends over at genu cell
sold out of their Dark Spot Corrector
and our listeners have been begging for
a restock biggie legged dog on your
hands and knees well I've got great news
just in time for the summer it's back in
stock geniuselle's famous Dark Spot
Corrector has it not one but three
Cutting Edge ingredients and goes to
work fast to Target sunspots dark spots
liver spots even old discoloration both
on your face and your hands you can now
enjoy your summer sun Beach and
barbecues without embarrassing spots
geniusell's most popular package also
features their summer Essentials such as
the best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun you
will be amazed at how quickly you see
the results or 100 of your money back
guaranteed I love the owner of this
company Coptic Christian from Egypt who
left there came over here for the
American dream go to geniusell.com
Knowles right now get your dark spot
corrector in the genius all most popular
package genius
most popular package all orders will
include a mystery luxury gift while
supplies last genucel.com
slash nulls right now go to
samaritanministries.org Knowles how are
you paying for your health care how's it
working out for you if it's working out
perfectly great okay cool if not listen
closely because I have a solution for
you a Biblical solution called Samaritan
Ministries Samaritan Ministries is a
community of Christians paying one
another's medical bills it's affordable
health care sharing and because it's not
Insurance there are no restrictive
networks here's how it works when a
medical need arises you choose the
health care provider that is right for
you and have a say in the treatment you
receive send your medical bills to
Samaritan Ministries they will notify
fellow members to pray for you and send
money directly to you to help you pay
those bills it could be more affordable
than what you are paying now and if it's
the right fit you can join anytime even
today check it out at
samaritanministries.org Knowles kowles
that is Samaritan Ministries dot org
slash Knowles speaking of power Brokers
turning to the 2024 race there's a
report out
with bad news for the DeSantis Campaign
which has struggled since its launch
suggesting that top donors are
considering a flip to Tim Scott
uh Tim Scott you know nice fairly
moderate Centrist Republican senator
from South Carolina
I don't know that I buy this report if
the report is real
come on man that's not going to work it
means that the donors who don't want
Trump are souring on DeSantis chances so
they're looking for an alternative
I I really like Tim Scott personally
it's not going to happen
just looking at the numbers looking at
the political realities it's not going
to happen could Tim Scott
in some World become the number two guy
to Donald Trump if the Santa's campaign
really totally collapses and all of the
anti-trump forces rally around Tim Scott
Maybe
I think though at this point
donors who are trying to take a
candidate from three percent to the
nomination
they're just setting their money on fire
DeSantis himself who's got almost 20
percent
the odds that he would be able to take
the nomination right now are quite low
and I know that people are very upset
with me for this guys I'm
I'm like the last conservative pundit in
America who's not actively working for a
presidential campaign and I'm just
calling it like I sees it and people are
pulling their hair and they're saying
but no but in 2016 but in 2012 but in
2008 I'm saying guys that doesn't matter
we haven't had an analog for this kind
of a primary since 1892 because that was
the last time that you had a one term or
running for a rematch
so yes Donald Trump is not the incumbent
but practically speaking in many ways he
is like the incumbent that's why these
other other guys are not going to catch
fire and the other problem here I love
Tim Scott he's a really nice guy
but Tim Scott is a very has a very
conciliatory tone he's really nice as
I've just said and if you think that
this moment in 2024 is the moment for
like a really nice conciliatory guy to
meet in the middle and work across the
aisle and all Shucks were all on the
same team
you don't know what time it is you got
to go get your watch fixed that that's
not where we are right now the two
candidates who have a real shot at the
nomination right now
or Trump and DeSantis and the left field
candidate who's done a lot better than a
lot of people predicted is Vivek Rama
Swami what do all three of them have in
common
they've all bucked GOP Orthodoxy and the
nice nice work across the aisle just cut
taxes ignore the culture they are all
extreme culture Warriors in their own
ways
and and they're the only guys with any
momentum whatsoever or any any real shot
at the moment donors you got to know you
got to know what time it is money cannot
buy you
the nomination money alone cannot buy
you the nomination just ask president
Jeb Bush
boy what a great clip that was
yeah you got to ring the bell subscribe
make sure you don't miss a single clip
or episode or interview or yes or no
game or face off subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel